Just keep hearing the fucking numbers!
(robotish voice) It's a broadcast, Mason.
The numbers are a Broadcast.
(robotish voice) You've been brainwashed.
THE NUMBERS...
THE NUMBERS, MASON...
WHAT DO THEY MEAN!?
ah.....
Let me just explain...
what is going on,
in case you've been living under a rock.
Basically, I am the cause of the "adpocalypse."
You may have heard of it.
"You know Pewdiepie is actually the cause of the adpocalypse"
"Pewdiepie singlehandedly ruined almost all of youtube"
That's right.
That was me.
Okay. I take full responsibility.
it's written ther-, I take full responsibility--
That was definitely me putting those ads
on those, uh....
Videos.
That was me.
That was all me.
You're right.
Uh, sumimasen.
The adpocalypse basically leading to a ton of ads pulling out of YouTube,
and uhhh...
effectively a ton of our videos
constantly getting demonetized.
constantly the yellow symbol flying across..
the board.
You probably heard a ton of creators complain about this already,
Just want to make sure we're on the same page.
Now recently a lot of youtubers struggling with the de--
the demonetization,
have noticed a striking
Sss...pattern
"...When a video gets demonetized..
it gets a FRACTION of the views.
Does anyone else experience this?"
(ticking sounds)
"Once it's yellow, It is removed from any form of recommendation or trending"
Even I, noticed this,
"I noticed this too, Make sense from a business perspective even though it's dumb as hell."
(more ticking sounds)
So basically, once the video hits yellow,
the views goes "hell"o
I mean, bye,
they go bye,
that's what I've noticed,
a lot of people did as well
okay,
but then YouTube--YouTube reply and be like
"Eh, no!
That's not the case!"
basically saying that
the yellow icon alone doesn't impact search and discovery
But, if the video is also not suitable for a wider audience,
then you might see a poor performance
So they're basically saying
"if a video gets to demonetized it has nothing to do with lower views
okay?
But if a video has...
ehhhh,
Explicit content
Then it's not gonna get as many views
but your video is demonetized...
Because you don't have explicit content."
Ehhh, they're saying yes, and no at the same time.
It's like tennis.
It's a going back and forth.
(tennis sounds)
we--we aye--
we dodged around the issue."
(COD:Black ops) Gah,
just keep hearing, the fucking numbers!
The numbers!
What do they mean?
Now something recently,
uh,
very interesting came to light,
Thanks to a study
that showed that according to their analysis,
YouTube is systematically suppressing content,
that have limited monetization
or have been completely demonetized.
How did they notice this you ask?
Through the numbers!
(COD:black ops) Focus Mason!
We are out of fucking time!
The numbers what do they mean?
(COD:black ops) Keep hearing the fucking numbers!
Just want to point out,
This is a Swedish study,
So you know 100% how legit it is.
Now, YouTube have a hidden variable
called "Excluded_Ads"
in the source code of all videos with monetization enabled
You can access this variable by right-clicking and selecting
"view page source"
then simply press ctrl F
and search for "excluded_ads".
If your video is demonetized,
It will have one of the following key variables:
102, 104 or 109
(COD: Black Ops) Mason: "Oh my god,
the numbers are real!!"
Unknown: They've always been real, Mason!
Let's go and check this out,
let's go to my demonetize section,
which I also like to call
all my content!
*claps*
Okay, okay, all right
Excluded
Ads
there we go
keep hearing the fucking numbers
Now after noticing these numbers
youtubers
started to try and figure out,
What are the numbers mean?
What are they mean?
Thanks to the channel "Nerd City"
the numbers so far that have been discovered
102:
profanity and rough language
104 means
sexually suggestive content
109: sensational and shocking
113: tragedy and conflict,
115: sensitive social issues.
I don't know, okay.
People are still trying to figure it out
And if your video got demonetized
do help out
and share the cause.
Butt
what the study also discovered
was that videos that did get demonetised
significantly
Got less traction
than the videos that were monetized,
at least if they have lower viewership
So what our research shows
is that demonetized videos,
especially with lower viewership,
are less promoted than monetized videos with the same viewership
to a very great extent
Such a significant difference can only be caused
if YouTube is actively devaluing demonetized videos
using some sort of function
So videos with lower viewership can't compete against monetized videos
But as the views gets higher,
more and more videos are able to push through
despite with the evaluation
Thereby causing the visible pattern in the graph,
which otherwise would not exist.
so basically,
uh
videos like mine
should technically push through
even if they do get demonetized,
but if you have a smaller channel,
uh
GOODBYE.
you need some prior knowledge,
and if you watched my last video on AI
then you will easierly understand
this video
isn't that great?
because, YouTube...
the way YouTube runs, its recommendation system
and their Demonetization system,
is run through an AI
a deep neural network,
which we know what that is
It's a self-taught AI
which basically means...
it's not YouTube going
"hey! do this! okay, huh?"
It's a- it's a- it's a- it's a-
Entity.
if people didn't fear AI before,
just think of how much I fear
the YouTube recommendation AI
There's basic- there--
There's document about this published-ized,
and it's actually really interesting
I love how advanced this is
especially if you go back,
because back in the day with--with the--
The reason for an AI to even exist to have recommendation videos
is because back in the day on YouTube
The only way you would find a video
was for searching the title, or the tags
Now people started to immediately
abuse this
by writing the exact same title
and the exact same tags as the video.
Remember boob girls--
Reply girls- sorry that's their name
They would basically show up in the recommended bar for popular videos
because they would copy their title and their tags.
So people started abusing
the system,
and it just didn't work anymore
and YouTube had to come up with something better
So it's really funny to me,
How this is, uh...they had--
this "advanced study" on neural networks.
It's thanks to boob girls
Thank You boob girls
now it's really interesting because uh--
A neural network needs a goal
an incentive.
They work just like human beings,
if you know because you watch my video,
for example the MarI/O
self-taught AI,
which was an AI that taught itself how to play Mario,
It's incentive
which was named in this case, Fitness,
Was increased by walking in the right axis.
You see the Fitness increases,
That's his goal.
And then through trial and error
Mario improves, and can play the game better.
YouTube's
recommendation works in the exact same way,
or in at least a very similar
where
It's incentive is based on watch time.
The--the AI takes videos
that they think will increase the watch time
test it on a few people
Did it increase watch time?
a--if the answer is yes?
Throw it--you know, throw it--
here's ah here's the video to everyone
because it increases watch time on YouTube
This one was demonetised
Uh, Most likely uh- go away, ok?
and it's a really interesting solution to this problem
because if you solely based
video recommendation on likes,
then, controversial videos wouldn't make it
to recommended
But at least now we can better understand why
demonetized videos
doesn't get recommended
or why they don't get as many views
Becuase recommended is a huge part of our viewership
since YouTube has really thrown out the whole subscription
idea more and more out the window
because their goal is to increase watch time
That's what gonna give them better ads
and it makes sense
I will say Tom Scott did a video about this
where he explains how the YouTube algorithm works
He explains his thousand times better than I do
But I did find it really interesting
how he pointed out that the flaw in this AI
Which is, that
even though its goal is to increase watch time,
it can't determine what the quality of the video is,
it doesn't know exactly
What- what the video is about,
what -what does it contain?
And that's what it's been trying to do
now with the demonetization in picture
where--where the AI will scan the video,
it will scan the thumbnail,
we know there's technology to do this
We can use an example here.
Here's my thumbnail.
It's a person.
It's okay
It scans the title,
it scans the description,
the tags,
and the caption
to determine if the video is
monetizable or not,
because there's no way YouTube would be able to do this on all its content because
An- it- so much is uploaded on YouTube every single day
it needs an AI to fully function
But I found it really interesting how he points out
the flaw in AI.
It can't tell the difference between videos that are suitable for children
made with education in mind
and
Creepy
trademark, infringing, unofficial efforts
it just knows
What kids click on
and what they watch.
so the YouTube algorithm promotes stuff that gets more watch time..
But it doesn't really know what it is
It can do its best effort, too,
And you can tell this is
Something that YouTube had to do last minute
because it recently came out
what people call Adpocalypse II,
and I'm not responsible for this one
Thank you.
Ads are pulling out now
because it was discovered that really creepy and disturbing videos were shown
and promoted to millions of kids
because it was picked up by the algorithm
and promoted to them
Tom predicted it,
it's kind of interesting
there was also a search result,
basically when you type in "how to..."
it showed up "how to have s*x with your kids"
it showed how to have sex with your kids.
It's weird.
Wasn't this video
Educational?
Don't we all understand each other a little better?
BUT THE NUMBERS?!
What do they mean?
Only you can tell us what the codes mean.
I find it really interesting because this is what happens constantly,
Where Youtube
can't say what they're doing
because if they explain what they're doing
people are gonna abuse the algorithm
but it also leads to the effect of people discovering numbers
and trying to figure out what they mean
and they--we have every right to trying to,
like this is our job.
This is our livelihood
We depend on this,
having the videos demonetized is a huge deal
and especially as we've seen now for smaller channels
Obviously we as creators, need to work together to figure out all these things, but at the same time YouTube
They need to hide the information from us, but
in--inevitably leads to chaos
every single time
Who wins here?
No one.
That seems to be a common census in all my videos.
Now is a great time
if you want to support your creators
Buy their merch, support their patron,
especially if they are smaller
Hopefully the AI will improve
that's what they're saying
and that's how self taught neural networks work.
This has been PewDiePie
leave a like
and
hopefully we can get this to trending
if you share,
like,
and watch the whole thing
twice
watch it again
Again
and again,
see this is what you really should be telling at the end of the video
Hey watch the video again,
shithead
you going somewhere?
Open a new tab
and click again!!
alright
squad fam out.
we did it Kyle,
we got it
(the terminator rises)
No!!!
NO!!